Scott Kirkpatrick: It’s a huge question
to say ‘What should I write?”
And I do my best to answer that in the easiest
way for new writers in my new book and I try
to break that down the best I can but I mean
it’s a really big question.
And the thing I certainly don’t want to
see any screenwriters run into is feeling
like they have to blindly guess.
I try to answer that in the book but if you
don’t have access to that in the book, the
best advice I can give to a screenwriter is…
Larry Wilson: What that story is and it’s
not that cliche to ‘Write what you know’
because I’ve never written because I’ve
never written a “know.”
I write fantastical worlds and supernatural
stories but write what you feel and write
what’s in your heart and write something
that means something to you.
Scott: You can go to a Red Box machine.
It used to be Blockbuster but those all turned
into cell phone stores.
Go to the Red Box machines, look at the independent
films on there.
So independent would be the family titles
at the bottom, look for the live-action ones
(usually with a dog or an animal on them)
and also look at the big studio films that
are…throughout the machine you’ll see
them in different spots.
Whatever a big studio film is look to the
ones that are right next to that.
Or go on Netflix and find a big studio movie
in the line up and then look at the independent
movie you’ve never heard of that is next
to it, that’s the independent Hollywood
zone.
That’s where I work, those are the scripts
that I’m in need of, that’s where I think
you’re going to get your best indicator
as far as genres, the genre themes you’re
going to see, the number of cast members,
all that information.
Larry Wilson: I was a script reader for for
God…probably a decade?
And I was reading seven-eight scripts a week.
And the rare one was the great script and
when you found that, that was a very exciting
day at the office.
And some times the really terrible scripts,
they were fun because they were so God-awful.
The ones that got really exhausting and really
innovative as a script reader who is sitting
there having to read a script, synopsize it,
write a comment about it and then pick up
another, read it, synopsis it…were the ones
who you could tell were written by people
who were looking at what last year’s hit
was and trying to imitate it.
Those were deadly and they were safe and bad
and any young writer (any old writer), anyone
who is just starting to write anything, write
something that you feel, write something that
comes from the heart.
Scott: I think screenwriters stand their best
chance for really getting noticed by knowing
what the business needs.
So it’s not coming in talking about how
passionate you are about the script.
It’s talking and speaking in a way that
answers to the needs of the production company,
the producer, the studio, etc.
There are tried and tested genres that are…they
just nail what the business lives on.
And if a young writer wants to come into the
business and just get their emails answered,
get their phone calls returned, it’s being
able to speak about the project and have it
answer to those things.
It’s going to be saying “I’m writing
a family film about this.
I’m writing a film about this and it’s
a very quick point.
It’s not a quick point.
It’s never a coming-of-age stories, it’s
never dramas.
It’s happier films, it’s the kind of films
you see on a Red Box machine.
That’s what Hollywood needs to stay in business.
And so if you’re coming to the table bringing
opportunities for Hollywood to continue staying
in business, they are going to continue paying
attention to you.
Larry: When I decided I was going to be writer
again and I decided I was going to do it with
Michael, in my mind I said (this sounds so
awful maybe) but I said “I’m going to
write a classic.
I’m not just going to write another movie.
We are going to create a classic.”
And who knows what that means and it sounds
obnoxious.
But we knew maybe…20 pages in…that just
something was happening and we weren’t thinking
about demographics, we weren’t thinking
about who the audiences was going to be.
We weren’t thinking about an “commercial”
aspects of it.
We were thinking what’s good, what’s funny,
what’s making us laugh, what’s moving
the story forward, what are the zaniest, craziest
ideas we can have.
And it happens with scripts and it happens
in your writing.
There are just times when you feel that you’re
in a zone and that you are so connecting with
yourself and you’re so connect with what
your vision is, that if you can get it on
a page, other people are going to see it and
feel it too.
Scott: At no point am I saying “Don’t
write dramas.
Don’t write comedies.
Don’t write the coming-of-age-story.”
If you have a fantastic idea for a movie,
I think a writer should hold onto it (just
hold onto it).
Get the commercial scripts out first, get
a reputation of a screenwriter who can deliver
what the systems needs, who can write quickly,
who can write well, who can write within budget
and get a couple of actual paid gigs and you’ll
get them.
If you go in the opposite way saying I know
what Hollywood wants, they want this…they
want these very deep dramas, they very deep
coming-of-age dramas and forcing them to do
that but you’re not going to get noticed.
But if you come in giving them what they want
which is Tween girl family films or Christmas
movies with dogs, women-in-peril thrillers,
these kinds of things, Hollywood pays attention
to you.
And once you are writing those and getting
noticed for that work and you have a collection
of contacts you can say “I have an interesting
idea.
Could this work?”
And then you can present those.
Larry: People may not think that BEETLEJUICE
is a personal movie.
It’s an intensely personal movie, it’s
intensely personal for Michael and me.
And I didn’t know I had a theme until I
had enough work to realize I had a theme and
almost everything I’ve written are about
broken families who are put back together
in some bizarre way because I came from a
broken family and so I like to think that
my work has a sense of art and a sense of
compassion and a sense of humanity no matter
how bizarre it is, now matter how weird the
world is, no matter how weird the worlds get.
And you’ve got to write something that you
feel and something that you write some passion
for or just why do it?
It’s too hard, it’s not an easy job.
Scott: I would take the high school script
over the foreign exchange one (hands down).
But I would take it and probably rebrand it
and make it junior high and make it more focused
on the tween girl audience knowing that nine
to 12-year-old girls are the most likely audience
to be renting movies and buying movies on
something like iTunes, Amazon or some other
platforms and I would see bigger numbers doing
that and I would make a really nice pink poster…see
this is how we’re talking.
You come in with an idea and then we target
an audience we know we need to hit and then
we create a concept around that and I can
already see the key art in my head and I would
go talk to my teams about that, I know how
much money we can make Internationally with
a movie like that.
I would take that writer and either have them
rewrite it or we’d hire a writer who had
experience to write the movie we’ve now
just created.
Larry: I personally imagine saying “Well
this was a hit, so I’m going to write my
version of that.
It’s not really what I care about, what
I feel but I can imitate it well-enough.”
I can’t imagine spending a year of your
life doing that but people do it all the time
and they usually write mediocre scripts.
Film Courage: Is being safe something that
has never appealed to you?
Larry: I don’t know how in my career and
in my life!
Safe hasn’t factored into it.
And not only the best decisions maybe but
I sort of like jumping off cliffs.
Scott: Look, comedies are fantastic and anyone
would be correct by saying that comedies are
very popular, high grossing movies, they absolutely
are.
The problem is the best way for a writer to
break into a Hollywood film career is to go
toward the independent space (not the big
studios).
There’s too much noise at the big studio
level and there’s way too many barriers.
Go to indie Hollywood, that’s where I work.
And that’s where most movies and content,
that’s where it comes from.
So on the comedies front, indie Hollywood
is not just thinking US and Canada, we’re
not thinking out domestic English speaking
markets.
We’re thinking global.
We get a lot of our money from overseas.
And the problem with most newbies writers
it the want to write something like AMERICAN
PIE, a really raunchy comedy or they want
to write a really smart comedy with high level
humor and witty dialogue.
Witty dialogue costs a lot of money to dub.
Social nuances in Russia or India or Japan
aren’t what they are here.
Not every country in the world celebrates
Thanksgiving and understands what the Super
Bowl means.
There are so many subtleties to the international
marketplace that even if you nail your comedy
script and make it wide enough for an English
speaking audience to understand, it’s a
very limited part of the world.
And the way a Hollywood executive or the way
a producer would read that is that’s a limited
cross section of money and I’m missing out
on a lot of other revenue that can come in.
So comedies are great, just keep them in your
back pocket.
Larry: When things are going well in my writing
and I think it’s true for all writers that
if you’re a intensely self-conscious for
who is your audience “Is this for the 12
to 16 year olds?”
If you’re doing that, you’re not writing
well and you get in a zone and your story
starts telling you, you’re not telling the
story, it’s emerging from some place within
you and that’s what BEETLEJUICE was.
And I used to say to Michael sometimes because
I could feel it going well and I’d say “Michael,
you know we are going to have a toy line!”
And he’d go “Shut up!
Shut up!
Let’s just finish the script.”
But it’s a very hard thing to explain…it’s
an epiphany after an epiphany and that you
feel like you’re just onto something bigger
than you.
Scott: Out of all the spec scripts in Hollywood,
the reason it’s not made it to fruition
is people writing the wrong thing.
So my view is this, there’s this stereotype
in Hollywood that every other waiter you meet
has a screenplay on the side, every real estate
agent is writing something on the side and
in truth that’s reality.
A lot of people come here with big Hollywood
dreams and want to write that great screenplay.
And people go “Oh there are not that talented,
they are writing bad scripts.”
Certainly there are a lot of bad scripts but
at the same time there are a lot of very talented
people who just aren’t writing the right
things.
They are not writing the right things, they
are not writing what Hollywood needs and they
are not presenting it in the way it needs
to be presented to get doors to open.
So if they just shift a few of those elements,
if they just write what Hollywood needs (which
are goldmine genres as we outlined in the
book), if they present their ideas in a way
that Hollywood needs to hear them which is
about pitching your script in a way that “This
is how my script helps your company.
This is how my script answers that need in
the Hollywood system.”
And then if you just get yourself out there
at the same time, that’s how you really
do it.
It’s not selling a one off script, it’s
building a career.